[Music]
Winsor can be the best and the most
terrible time of the year at the same
time and some people experience it in
the funniest way make sure you watch
this video until the end to see what
it's like to live in the coldest place
on earth if you love winter as much as
we do don't forget to subscribe and
please give this video a big thumbs up
today we're showing you 20 hilarious
pictures of people vs. winter the fake
car if you live in Canada you know how
hard it is to find parking in the big
city during a storm because you can't
park on the road during snow removal
this guy from Montreal called Simon the
prize didn't have a car but he wanted to
live this problem too
this is why he decided to make a car out
of snow he just wanted to trick the snow
removal guys but he tricks the police
instead a police officer stopped to look
at this masterpiece and even called for
backup they finally left him a note
saying you made our night with a smiley
face watch for ice unless you plan to go
ice skating on the road no one likes ice
but do you know why it's so slippery
that's because there's a thin layer of
liquid water on top of solid ice but the
problem is that no scientist knows why
ice has such a layer this brown bear put
on his white lab coat to do a little
experiment and solve this problem
unfortunately it ended up being much
more complicated than he thought it
would be that's because he slipped on
ice - if only bears could read he would
have known that he should watch for ice
that's what they said some people say
that you need to put your wipers up when
it snows and they are probably just
making fun of you this guy found out
about it the hard way when he saw that
his wipers were completely frozen up in
the air we think that some people give
this advice because they find it easier
to clear off windshields when their
wipers are up and they don't freeze onto
the glass but when you are stuck in a
storm like this you probably won't make
that mistake ever again no matter what
will forget about everything when we'll
be comfy and warm in our car the crash
people from Canada really do love to
hate winter and we clearly understand
why during a snowstorm many cars crashed
into each other in Montreal a couple of
cars lost control but then a bus lost
control - followed by another car
and another bus people tried to help
them but they ended up being a part of
the crash - just when we thought that it
couldn't get worse the snow removal guys
crashed into them in total police
confirmed that 14 cars were involved in
this little incident that's just another
normal day in Canada is it winter in the
United States Americans live winter in a
really different way actually we don't
even know what season it is in Chicago
right now that's because one person is
wearing a pair of shorts and a t-shirt
while the other has a winter coat and
winter hats then there is a girl in the
back who just seems to be wearing a
simple jacket that's what happens when
the temperature always changes suddenly
we never know what we're supposed to
wear and some people don't even have
what it takes to face winter we think
that the guy is calling his mom to ask
her to bring him a coat the Russian
winter at least if you live in Russia
you know when it's cold it's cold these
three women decided to take pictures
outside when it was negative 67 degrees
Celsius in Moscow don't worry it's not
that bad it was negative 71 degrees
Celsius in 2013 in this city kids
usually go to school even when it's
negative 40 degrees Celsius outside but
they decided to make an exception on
that day they all went to the mall to
buy some white mascara and Anastasia
Rose diva was one of the girls who loved
this trend with her eyelashes completely
covered in snow she looks just like a
snow queen the temperature what do you
think is the coldest place on earth many
people guessed that it would be the
North Pole but if he lives in Canada you
would be wrong some Canadians woke up
one morning to find out that Montreal
was probably one of the coldest places
on earth at that time it was negative 26
degrees Celsius on that day which is not
that bad but when you compare it to
other places you see that it was
negative 21 degrees Celsius in the North
Pole negative 17 degrees Celsius in
Antarctica and negative 2 degrees
Celsius in Siberia
we think that we are going to move in
with Santa Claus for next winter once a
beer no matter what some people found a
way to take advantage of the situation
in the comfort of their home a little
snowstorm is not a reason to stop the
party it should actually be invited to
the party anyway there is no way they
could leave their home when they saw how
much snow was outside when they open to
the door this is why they decide
turn it into a little fridge to make
sure that their beers would stay cold
and if they ever lose one they will
simply have a nice surprise during the
spring the bathroom break just because
you stay inside doesn't mean that winter
is always your friends that's because we
all know how cold it can get ramier in
the bathroom and no king should sit on a
throne unless it's warm
unfortunately the king of this house
couldn't afford a heated toilet seat
this is why they decided to take a
blanket make a hole in it and put it on
the toilet we don't know if this is a
good idea because the blanket will not
be cleaned for too long no matter what
it was a good reason to take a hilarious
picture where's the pupper come on
humans you are so weak a little
snowstorm we'll never be able to stop a
big puppy from enjoying a day outside
this courageous young pup just decided
to jump into the snow and have a whole
lot of fun he might have underestimated
the amount of snow but he will never
forget this awesome decision come on and
join him outside we know that we will
all end up hating snow when we grow up
so make sure you appreciate the wagging
tail of a puppy who enjoys the snow for
the first time in his life the murder
unfortunately some people are not ready
for winter and this snowman learned it
the hard way we can already imagine a
couple of kids who were forced to spend
some time outside and decided to turn
their negative emotions into something
hilarious they were too lazy to build a
class of snowman and this is why they
ended up putting them next to each other
around the tree just add some sticks and
some X's for the eyes and you end up
with a crime scene even though this is
not what their parents expected we bet
that they couldn't help but laugh when
they saw this we just hope that this one
won't come to life like Frosty the
Snowman the artists there are many ways
he can turn something into a work of art
during winter but this guy never thought
that he would create something wonderful
during his lunch break he just wanted to
eat some ramen noodles outside but he
quickly found out that it was a bad idea
this is why he decided to turn it into
something better it was so cold outside
that the ramen noodles stayed in place
when he took some with a spork but
instead of complaining this guy took
advantage of the situation and decided
to take a picture of this beautiful
scene the Sahara do you know that the
entire continent of Antarctica is
considered a desert because
gets a very little precipitation this is
what makes it the largest desert in the
world but Antarctica has some
competition now that's because it
started snowing in the Sahara this is a
rare event which has taken place just
three times in 40 years and Karine Lucia
tada
an amateur photographer decided to
capture this moment with a camera while
most of the pictures simply look
gorgeous is also really fun to see his
awesome selfie he is probably the only
one who has a picture like that on
Instagram
don't forget your boots it's kind of
hard to forget your boots when you go
outside during the winter but there is
always one of your weird friends who is
going to surprise you with a weird story
about this anyway this cute little dog
really wished that he had forgotten his
boots that's because he doesn't know how
to walk with them he doesn't understand
that his little paws are touching the
ground but he can't feel the ground
because he is wearing little boots what
is happening maybe he should walk on two
feet as humans do
but don't walk on those two feet little
pupper the fashionista this girl's did
wear boots but someone should have told
her that wearing heels was not a good
idea when you're walking on ice you do
look cute when you're walking on the
sidewalks during the spring but you look
a little clumsy when you slide down the
sidewalk during the winter at least
someone gave her some instructions to
learn how to walk she just needs to find
enough balance to have the time to read
what's written on this sheet of paper
you don't these heels anyway you're
already tall enough girl you probably
have vertigo when you walk on stilts
like these the bikini contest we do know
that you can't wait for winter to be
over but wearing a bikini won't make
summer come faster but it might make you
look hotter than you have ever been
before
in April 2013 Siberia when the world
record for bikini skiing 700 women and
men in swimsuits were lucky enough to go
skiing on a very hot day and they were
not the only ones who had crazy ideas
like that the previous record was set in
Canada when 250 people came down the
slope wearing a swimsuit would you be
crazy enough to go skiing in a bikini
whoo we certainly would the fall you're
not the only one who keeps slipping on
ice the professionals do it too and when
they fall they fall in a terrible way
ice skating isn't for everyone
mostly when you see that even the best
people can fail we usually see the guy
holding the girl up in the
but this time they decided to switch
places to show that women can be strong
- you're not saying this girl is not
strong but that guy is probably heavier
than what she imagined or maybe that's
just the way they're supposed to do this
figure who's the puppy who's a good boy
no seriously who's the good boy there
are two dogs in this picture we don't
understand which one is the real one
we think that this woman did an amazing
job at recreating her best friend with
snow unfortunately the real dog doesn't
seem really happy is he upset because he
thinks that he looks better than that
because the other dog is bigger than him
or because the new snow dog gets more
attention we wouldn't be surprised if
the big puppy ended up peeing on the
competition this is his territory the
smiley faces at least some people are
happy to see that it's winter cars love
spending time outside they even like to
make sure that they are covered in snow
to hide from their owners who want to
take them for a ride just look at the
cars that have been surprised by a
photographer when they thought that no
one was looking at them
this is what your car does when you're
not looking at it they like to stick out
their tongue and smile for no reason
even though one is really upset today
because his owner forgot to lock the
doors
who said that cars didn't have feelings
the coldest place on earth we have
learned previously that the North Pole
is not always the coldest place on earth
but where is it then in Omnicon a tiny
village in siberia the temperature can
drop to negative 96 degrees Celsius
sometimes there is even a sign that
warns people when the temperature drops
under negative 60 degrees Celsius which
we'll never see in many other countries
there is even a sign that reads the pole
of cold in Cyrillic what do you like to
do during winter don't be shy to answer
in the comments section down below we
love to hear what you think and that's
it for 20 hilarious pictures of people
vs. winter for more stories like this
don't forget to subscribe and please
give this video a big thumbs up thanks
for watching and see you next time
[Music]